granblue Fantasy Versus is based on a
property that's incredibly popular in
Japan thanks to a successful mobile game
but relatively unknown everywhere else
vs is for all intents and purposes
granblue fantasies debut on the world
stage okay I'm all set
[Music]
developed by Arc System Works known for
its excellent fighting game adaptations
of Dragon Ball Z and persona 4 grand
blue Fantasy Versus has a strong core
thanks to unorthodox gameplay mechanics
that delicately balance depth with
approach ability while introducing
interesting new ideas of its own the
extra flourishes that serve as a nod for
fans or aim to adhere to the RPG routes
with on occasion but the experience as a
whole hold its own thanks to the
strength of its fundamentals as a
ground-based fighting game versus has a
much slower pace of play than most anime
fighters it places a heavier focus on
normals and special moves instead of
partner assists and lengthy touch of
death combos at a higher level
it's about footsies precisely execute
mix ups smart use of the universal
overhead and the occasional frame trap
for newcomers of which there's likely to
be many given the popularity of granblue
fantasy it's a much more stable ground
to find for you fighting game veterans
will naturally have an advantage but for
everyone else the mountain doesn't seem
as steep to climb Auto combos a common
mechanic in access games have been
included which means that a complete
newcomer can pick up a controller and
press an attack bar repeatedly to
execute basic combos these strings of
attacks are effective but limited in
damage and applicability without the
addition of a special move to the string
and is here that granblue Fantasy Versus
starts to throw in unique ideas that
make for interesting moment-to-moment
fighting special moves are executed
using a traditional combination of
directional inputs and attack button
presses but there are also shortcuts
mapped to R 1 or R 1 + ur direction the
added layer to this is like an RPG each
of these special moves goes on a
cool-down after being used with the
length of that cooldown being longer if
you take a shortcut to execute this
system creates an interesting meta game
that lends a degree of unpredictability
to fights especially at higher levels in
most traditional fighting games there
are certain movements that serve as
tells giving keen-eyed players some
indication of what's about to happen but
that's not the case in granblue fantasy
vs. however since the shortcut commands
can instantly execute special moves it
sounds like a nightmare to deal with and
admittedly it can be but also creates a
fascinating dynamic that hasn't been
explored much in the past the cooldown
system layered on top of these shortcuts
presents
strategic decision-making moment where
you weigh up the pros and cons of using
shortcuts versus having an ability
temporarily taken out of play and how
long it's unavailable for there are also
multiple options for guarding if
directional inputs are used to manually
guard just defenses available with
proper timing however if the dedicated
god button is used it becomes possible
to dash out the dedicated God bar and
also makes blocking cross-ups more
consistent but just defense becomes
unavailable again granblue fantasy vs.
asks you to weigh up whether you want to
take the easy approach or put in the
work for more of a payout what I've
enjoyed most is engaging with the
technical side of play when I feel
confident but then switching to the
simpler options when I'm feeling
overwhelmed or want to be safer that
process of trying to hone the skills
needed to do that effectively has been
incredibly gratifying all that is to say
that fundamentally granblue Fantasy
Versus has a robust and intricate set of
fighting game mechanics all right
another victory for me it's a shame then
that the game doesn't leverage this for
its RPG quest mode and instead relies on
shallow button mashing that was in this
mode look and feel more like the mobile
RPG version of granblue fantasy but it's
not turn-based instead you have direct
control over characters and must
dispatch waves of incoming enemies in
something that feels somewhere between a
classic side-scrolling beat'em up and
Tekken's force mode however the enemies
present little to no challenge and have
very little health so they can usually
be killed off with a couple of heavy
attacks as a result there's little
reason to use some of granblue fantasy
versus more interesting ideas why use a
special move when spamming a single
attack bond gets the job done
occasionally boss characters appear but
they don't force change in approach the
all-out attack is the smartest and
easiest thing to do most of the time
other members of the fighting games cost
occasionally appear and in these account
battles take the form of a traditional
typical one-on-one fight however these
characters are mostly there to be
sandbagged so they can be added to your
party
the unsatisfying gameplay makes the
cliche forgettable story about a bunch
of sky pirates freeing their friends
from evil and battling an empire even
more tiresome to sit through
oh goodness sake the RPG quest mode is
also where the grand balloon fantasy
mobile games data elements appear you
unlock unique weapons for completing the
main story quests but you don't actually
get to use any of them instead they all
get thrown into what is effectively a
bucket and their combined power then
raises the attack attributes of your
character enemies have elemental
alignments and using opposing ones will
grant bonus damage but manually crafting
loadout is time-consuming and
unnecessary when an option to automate
and optimize exists
ultimately the gotcha elements end up
being a throwaway novelty instead of a
valuable wrinkle to gameplay granblue
Fantasy Versus has a comprehensive suite
of training missions that cover
everything from basic moves and specials
to advanced combos strategies and
specific matchups any and all time spent
there is more valuable than in the RPG
quest mode especially since that's what
will be tested when you head online
currently the game servers aren't as
populated as they will be post launch
but in the time we spent playing online
the experience was generally smooth
granblue Fantasy Versus presents a set
of systems that are distinct and unique
without putting up unnecessary hurdles
for those that are there just to get a
hit of granblue Arc System Works has
cleverly meshed RPG and fighting game
mechanics and the way that manifests in
the core one-on-one battles is really
exciting in other respects namely the
campaign story mode and its gacha
stylings leaves a lot to be desired in
bringing granblue to the wider world Arc
System Works hasn't put his best foot
forward but vs. is definitely a game
where you can come for the fantasy and
stay for the fight
[Music]